Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's welcome to another episode of Conner's clinic live podcast. Today we have a special guest my friend Mike Tiggler, and he is a special guest for me because we use his equipment.
Fairly exclusively for our patients, and we really have to keep him healthy because we're dependent on him. So, but I want to get him talking about how he started using the right machine, how he got into frequency therapy and how he started this company.
I want to give people a lot of confidence because we've been using Mike's equipment. I was trying to think of this Mike when we started when I bought my first F-117.
I should have been like 2010 maybe. Yeah, I would say at least a thousand years ago. Yeah, at least that. We used to mainly at our office for a while. I told other people the story of how we got to where we said everybody home with a right though.
But this is going to be about Mike. And so let's just jump into this. I want to talk to Mike about how did you get started in this is such a weird thing for somebody who's not maybe medical professional to get started into.
Dr. Conner has always been interested in alternative medicine and things like that. But back in 2003, I was seeing a doctor named Dr. Gary collar. I think he's retired now, but he was out of zealot mission. And he was trying to help me with some of my issues.
And he had acquired a right device back then it was called a beam rate. And he couldn't figure out how to run it. I was building a website for him as well. So he says, hey, why don't you take this home for a couple of weeks see if you can figure it out and run it for while see what it does. So that was my first contact with it. But at the same time, I was doing research because I was building his website on the history of royal right and frequency delivery.
So I got the system home. It was first time it was pretty advanced. It was a computerized system. It was an old DOS type system.
That was my that was our first right machine, too. Was it. Yeah, but you know what I'm talking about. Yeah, so they have this big ball up there and everything. And so I had a few friends over and you know we saw some good results with that. I was pretty amazed and it's stuff you couldn't placebo.
But at some point, I had to return it. Well, back then at the ice, it was around $6,000. And so I called the company ended up with the order on the phone. And we began talking, but we had different backgrounds culturally at the time.
And my background was musician and his background I found out later on was used car salesman. So we both approached this culturally differently. And I'm not being intended to be critical of the owner because culture affects how we we determine what we do or what we don't do.
But in the musical culture, people don't realize this musicians never pay for music. They only pay for hardware.
And it's just an unspoken word. If I know a song or I know a piece, I share it with you. You share it with me.
We don't buy music. If you know something, that's how I get it. And I know something that's how you get it. But we always pay for hardware.
The amplifiers, the instruments, all that's always paid for that. We understand that. But new music. No, you don't pay for it. That's, that's not the culture. That's what I'm on.
That's part of the art. That's the art of music that your shit. It is exactly. And so when I'm on the phone with the current owner at the time, I says, well, Lynn, I says, how do I, how do I get new songs? How do I get new music or new programs from you?
And he says, well, you buy another machine. And I says, Lynn, I pretty much put it this way. I'm not going to spend $6,000 on another grand piano to get another version of chopsticks from you.
See, that's not my culture. And he says, well, you know, use car salesman. Look, if you want new features, you got to buy another car. See, we saw.
This is a classic of different views, a matter. So I hung up the phone. And at that point, I decided I need to build my own instrument because I need something that's not only programmable, but upgradable.
And I don't want to have to go out and buy something brand new every time that kind of money just to get one or two programs. So.
I found another company that actually sold a board. I still use that company that actually had a computer on board. It was programmable. It was flexible. And it was upgradable.
And I began working with them. I only ordered a machine with the intent that I was going to own my own. I had no intent that this would become a business or I would share this with anyone else.
And so I got the thing finally working with the help of a relative of mine who had more skills than I at the time and electronics.
And I began running it. And then another doctor friend of mine, he said, Dennis, he says to me, he says, hey, I'd like one of these.
This is where you can have mine. I'll build myself another one. So he got the first one. He still has it. And I tried to get it back from him, but he won't let me have it. So I.
He said, no, you're not getting this one back. This is number one. So.
So regardless, at that point, then other people begin calling. And I eventually went from owning my own says over a few years, several hundred people had my device.
And here was this.
This all started in 2003. And I would say somewhere around 2006, seven, eight.
You know, somewhere, at least by 2006, there was quite a bit of devices out there. So I went back to the board maker and he began customizing my program to make it unique to us.
So the first thing we added was what's called an update frequency button. And this is what makes what we do so unique, because now you're part of our culture when you own our device.
If you want new programs, you simply click update frequencies and it downloads all the new things, all the new changes for free. You never pay for it into your system.
Can I stop you there? Can I stop you there? One second, Mike, because I want to buy this, because this is really important to me and our patients. When would I write a program for a patient.
That doesn't get changed when you update frequencies. But just in the last couple of years, they were talking and, you know, near the end of 2022 right now.
With all this COVID stuff going on, you had, you've had multiple COVID coronavirus programs that with that frequency update, now people got that additional program to use during these crisis type situations. That was just such a huge blessing to people.
And we're at a 13th edition. In fact, we just released the COVID variants. I think it's called B4B5 program. That was actually donated by a spinoff company that only develops custom programs for our users. They donated it to us.
But we have over 5,000 users and many of those will donate programs, not all of them by any means. But when we get something new and it's tried and tested, for example, we had a doctor call. He's a fairly new client of ours.
And he discovered some research that went back 10 years. But this stuff, it has a way of disappearing, getting buried.
And there were 4 or 5 proven frequencies in this very long article and study that was done that indicated they had some positive impacts, for example, against cancer.
And when he first sent it over to me, I'm a pretty busy guy. And I'm looking at all this stuff. And then he calls me. And he says, hey, did you get that article says, yeah, but I didn't see anything in there I could use. He says, well, yeah, there's 4 or 5 frequencies in there for cancer that were discovered.
I said, really? So I started looking at it closer. And within an hour, those are added to our cancer sets for our general cancer program. And then we release a critical update to all of our users to say we have a critical update update now. And we tell them what the program is, it was updated.
So they know what to look for. And some of those folks need it. Some of them don't need that program. But that's how it works. And here again, people aren't charged for this.
So they have that extra frequencies to use for their family, if they need it. It's huge, huge. I mean, it is like a community.
People sharing and trying to help other people get better. That's what life's supposed to be about, right.
Exactly. And see, once we start the culture, they're getting things. They're not paying for new music, because I call it. And when they discover something, they give it back to us. Nobody's asking to get paid.
Right. And that's the culture we created. So I'm not a used car salesman. You don't have to find another car or another device or another instrument to learn another piece of music.
We're going to keep giving you new music. And as a result, the device that you purchased, say in 2013 or 2012, 10 years later is actually better.
We at one point had 350 programs. There's now over 2400. Yeah. And we keep finding new ones. Or we're adjusting the current ones.
And so we've done some massive updates through the years as well to improve the functionality and the output of the device.
And here again, this is phenomenal. I, for example, I own a Tesla. The car I bought in 18 was better in 2022 because you get free updates that improves the functionality of the vehicle.
That's the culture over there as well. It's very similar to what we've been doing for years.
So, but it makes a huge difference. We got, we get feedback as well. We have a few really good people that are frequency sensitive. They'll tell us what's working for this month's cold and flu.
And generally speaking, that's with it's non-COVID. It's pretty good for about four to six weeks, whatever they find out. So I think yesterday we released the 2006 fall program. It's an old program that seems to be working and a 2018 program.
You just run them back to back. So my son just called for example this morning on his job. Some guy coming sick. It's non-COVID got him started.
And we loaded up that program and virtually we just stored it inside the machine. So he don't have to plug into computer. He flips the switch and they'll run it for him.
They auto run. Yeah, it is auto run. It's incredible. And that's another unique feature because what we've developed.
Even though you use your computer to send it the information over there. Our device is a lot like a printer. Once you click print, the really the computer is not doing anything anymore.
We sent that information to the device. And instead of clicking print, you click run on our device and it prints that data into the frequency generator, which has a computer on board.
And most of these generators are sold. They don't have a computer on board. There's no computer chip. They're relying on that device to continue.
Whether it be a handheld device or something else to continue to feed that information in.
They don't run standalone. And this virtually you could you could put a program in. We do it for nighttime sets. Maybe you've done this with some of your people.
We have obvious people that don't own computers, but they're struggling with something will load the set in. Ship the machine told let the switch.
And it'll run for six, seven hours. We stack the programs. They feel they would need.
Right. That's actually how I run my cancer program is on an auto run.
I just put my frequencies in one program, stacked it and then just put it on a run because I'm lazy.
So yeah, I do all my netway. I actually I brought off a desk and I walked in the office loaded up.
That's how I do all my program. So I want to talk about you right now where you see the F-122.
We have number of patients that have an F-117. You had something before that F-110.
There was an F-110 and if you really go back farther was what was called a T-150.
Okay, so I don't I've never seen either one of those. So I started utilizing yours when you had the F-117 TD or 2008 died somewhere around there. I actually have one of the first ones I bought from you.
Right. I still use we have two at home. So I typically use the F-122 that I that I got for you a couple years ago.
And when you first came on with those and then I still have that one of those first F-117s that we use at home on a Windows 7 computer.
Right. Right. And it works. Perfect. We have one issue with that machine in 13 years.
And, you know, my wife uses that, you know, all the time. So it's just, they're very hearty unless you're dropping the thing or something.
Right. You know, they're pieces of electronic device. You got to be careful with. But we've never had an issue. And we traveled with those two.
You know, carrying it in the suitcase, wrap it in a towel or a sweatshirt and just never had a problem with it.
And the thing about our device is I dealt with engineers for the years and I'm not an electrical engineer.
I tell people what do you know what do you do for a living. I said, I'm a mad scientist, you know, but engineers, they're not trained on high voltage.
They're trained on either if they're electronic engineers, they're on low voltage or if they're electricians, it's 12240.
Yeah. So an F-122 runs, it is peak about 1800 volts and your old F-117 runs 1200.
So when I was developing this product, if I talk to an engineer, it was always you can't do that. You can't do that. You can't do that.
Because they're looking at things from a much lower voltage. And they're in a box, unfortunately, most of them can't think out of the box.
And so finally, I just had to get rid of these people. And just here, I'm ordering these parts, we're putting them in, let's just see what happens.
Because you have no technical guidance, they will give you, other than no, it will not work.
And in reality, things do work. I'm not saying that I haven't smoked a few things. I smoked a lot of things.
And I'm not talking about this way, I'm talking about my machine. Just for those that got some other culture, I'm not in that one.
But you know, give you an example, one of the latest releases that came out about a year ago.
And it's something you don't have to have, but some people want it.
It's called the jackhammer. But I came up with an idea three years ago because there are individuals that want more range, but they cannot afford to hire up with ball.
Now, the idea was there, but I couldn't develop it. I couldn't figure out how to do it. But it always sat in the back of my head.
And about six, eight months ago, I finally, in my mind, I figured out how I could do it.
How do you up, how do you up the output of this ball, 256 times? How do you do that? You talked to an engineer, they're going to have some very expensive gadget.
And they'll spend months developing this thing with all kinds of schematics and prints. I grabbed a piece of plastic and a piece of metal, a screw and an alligator clip in a wire.
And the first test, I actually jumped the output over 500 times, but the machine smoked in about 10 minutes. It was just way too much. So I had smoke coming out of the hyperdrug.
So, but I had it, I had it figured out, you know, but how do you figure this out with a piece of metal plastic and alligator clip in a wire.
If you saw inside the actual unit, it's, it's a very simplistic way I do things. But this is the upside of not being an engineer because it's like a paperclip. It's so simple.
But an engineer who's been trained and he can't pick a simplicity. It's always as complexity to get something resolved and they're in that box.
But, you know, it works. It works incredibly well. We had to test it for about two or three months to make sure we wouldn't fry anything.
Is it a necessary thing? People ask me, I said, well, probably not. But there's eyes people, they're, they're not happy with a corvette. They want a Ferrari. They want to rise the ride. They want all the speed they can get. So we have devices here for that kind of culture.
And feel they, they, they need everything maximum. And so we, we have those devices. But here again, in the development, it doesn't happen overnight. If you saw my product, if you took off the hood or you opened up a jackhammer, you just say, well, that's simple.
It is very simplistic. But nobody realizes the amount of months or years it took to figure it out. Yeah.
I'll do it. That's simple.
So that's one of the things I tell people what I love about you and your company.
And what I love about your company is that you're constantly innovating and researching and developing with the idea of the outcome in mind of how we're going to help more people.
Try to keep your prices down all the time. Try to make this reasonable for people to, to be able to have one in their home.
You just moved a couple of years ago, was it to a different building?
Time flies because I think it's been at least eight years now.
Oh, my God.
So at one point, this was actually in the basement of my house.
And now we occupy a building that's about probably at least, I don't know if it's four, five thousand square feet.
We got a big warehouse. You'll see a picture of it on the about page on our website.
But when COVID hit, we went wall to wall. It got scary.
Fortunately, I was smart enough at the time that I had a lot of inventory.
But within a matter of two weeks, they about wiped us out.
But we were still able to deliver.
There has been as you know, supply chain issues.
But I have a huge investment in stock over there that I keep all the time because
you see, and you know, and I know we're not selling shoes.
We're fighting for people's lives.
Right.
And so, you know, a shoe salesman, if he runs out of the shoes, you want big deal.
But if I run out of a simple component, and I can't finalize the product,
this is more than me not making a sale.
This, this would resolve individuals who need this product, I feel,
to have an impact on their health and their life and their family's life as well.
And so, you know, I lost a lot of sleep.
I know you have two, anyone that's in this situation will.
But I tell people, there's two types of people in this world.
And they're both good people.
You have the group that gets up every morning, they go to work.
And that's okay.
They're trying to provide for themselves or family.
But then you got to sell the group.
They get up and they go to war.
Every day, they get up, they're going to war.
And if you watch a soldier war, he's not just fighting for his country.
They may say that he's fighting for everybody in the trenches with him.
And he's trying to save the lives of others, not just his own life.
And he's willing to make that sacrifice.
And it's just how we're built.
There's different people.
And to be in this type of business, you've got to be willing to make a sacrifice for others.
And keep your eye on the ball.
And this is about helping others, not just profits, sales, things like that.
Well, and my staff fully don't act as they're all in the boat with that with me with that too.
It's like you just never turned off because it's always a fight.
The powers that be the three-letter organizations out there are constantly trying to destroy us.
And it's, it's, it just is what it is.
And if you're not willing to fight that fight, I used to tease the doctors.
And it's like, if you're not willing to fight that kind of fight, then just don't even think about trying to treat cancer patients or use a knife or try to help these really help people because it's not the same as a regular practice.
No, it's totally different.
And here again, it goes back to your culture again, how you were raised, and some of your genetics or where your head said you.
And some of us are willing to take risk.
And if you're going to be in this business, you're at risk.
But it's the same time.
Can you sleep at night?
Knowing that if you don't take the risk, somebody could die.
Right.
And that's something that you, you just can't, some of us can't get a lot of our heads.
Well, and you can sleep, I sleep very well at night because what I just think of the patients that are still alive that were supposed to be dead.
Right.
Months, years, decades ago, that are so thankful that, you know, they followed this type of therapy.
So that's what I thank you.
Well, I want to have you back on our programs.
You know, true right out of Kalamazoo Michigan.
I've been to your true right conferences and spoke at them many times.
I don't know if you're planning on doing any of those again, but you just get to the point of overwhelmed with trying to keep up with production.
We just try to keep people educated as much as possible.
Thank you, Mike.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
And we'll get invite out to you to get back on.
And we can get, I really want to get into some of the technical stuff because I'm certainly not a physicist.
And you develop these.
I would like to get into the different scalar waves and the carrier waves.
And that kind of unstepped that people are interested in hearing as well.
Next time.
All right.
Thank you.